the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
i do apologize for taking such a long
break from these videos but sometimes i
like to try other things to see what
else works
if any of you would like early access to
my videos and are able to show some
support to the channel then consider
checking out my patreon account i would
really appreciate that
as you all know i have been making a
video for each chapter from the first
book a game of thrones
in this video we will be discussing jon
snow's very first
chapter as of right now we are still in
winterfell shortly after king robert
baratheon's arrival
the chapter begins as we go inside
winterfell's main dining hall
during the feast now we will go inside
the mind of jon snow
as we see the story continue to unfold
through his eyes
like most of the chapters thus far this
one starts off by setting up the scene
one of the things i find really
fascinating about this scene is how many
kings
and or future kings are in winterfell at
this very moment
obviously robert baratheon is the king
at the very beginning of the story
but then we have joffrey baratheon tom
and baratheon
rob stark jon snow bran stark
and maybe even one more depending on
whether you believe in the theory or not
anyway shall we begin during the
celebration of robert baratheon's
arrival
we find out jon snow is not allowed to
sit with everyone
else this is something we did learn in
the show as well
john's ever so loving stepmother lady
catelyn stark
thought it might be disrespectful to let
a bastard sit among the royal family
therefore john had to sit all the way at
the other end of the hall
having jon feel like an outcast in his
own home definitely had a negative
effect on him
but on this night it did not bother him
as much as you would think
every once in a while jon snow was glad
he was a bastard
and tonight was one of them jon realizes
this as he fills another cup of wine
since he is sitting so far away from
everyone there is really no one there to
stop him
so jon fills his cup then settled back
down in his seat among the younger
squires and drank
the sweet fruity taste of summer wine
filled his mouth and brought a smile to
his lips
in this moment it sure is good to be a
bastard
go ahead john drink up buddy enjoy it
now while you can
because life will only get worse from
here on out and enjoy it he did
jon was finding that he had a man's
thirst on this evening
every time he would finish a glass
everyone around him would urge him to
fill another
now this is when george rr martin does a
great job at describing everything
happening inside winterfell
this helps us visualize the welcoming
feast
the great hall of winterfell is alive
with sights and sounds and smells
the room is filled with the hazy smoke
and heavy with the smell of roasted meat
and fresh baked bread
the walls are covered in stark baratheon
and lannister banners
you can hear the sound of music the
crackling of fire
in the low mutter of a hundred different
drunken conversations
when the chapter begins they were
already four hours into the celebration
as i said before jon snow had to sit at
the end of the hall
but the rest of the starks were seated
with the royal family
now another one of the good things about
jon getting to sit down at this end of
the hall
is no one had to worry about keeping
their mouth shut around all the fancy
folk
jon was enjoying himself as he heard his
companions tell stories of battle
and betting in the hunt jon thinks who
he is sitting with
is far more entertaining than robert
baratheon's children
now i would agree with that but i also
think jon might be telling himself this
so he doesn't feel bad about not getting
a seat at the main table he doesn't want
to be left out
but i believe this is his way of looking
at the wine glass half full
at the beginning of the feast jon
watched as everyone entered the hall
he was able to get a good look at
everyone as they went by and you better
believe
john was judging every single one of
them and i must say
he did a great job at seeing right
through everyone this night
lord eddard stark entered the hall first
he had the honor of escorting the queen
cersei lannister
jon soon realizes cersei is as beautiful
as everyone says
after walking her to the high table ned
helped cersei to her seat
john notices cersei never so much just
looked at him
even at only 14 years old john could see
right through cersei's fake smile the
next one to enter the hall was king
robert baratheon himself
he had lady catelyn stark on his arm
john immediately notices how
disappointing of a king he is
jon had always heard ned tell stories of
robert about how he was the demon of the
trident
the fiercest warrior of the realm a
giant among men
but jon only saw a fat washed up old man
all of the children begin to enter next
little three-year-old rickon was first
close behind him was rob who was
escorting myrcella on his arm
john noticed the shy look she gave rob
john decided she was insipid
and jon thought how does rob not realize
how stupid she is
then we'll see jon's sisters escort
cersei's sons
arya had to walk in with the little fat
boy tommen
who had hair longer than hers then of
course
sansa came in with joffrey baratheon
john did not like joffrey
or the bored disdainful way he looked at
winterfell's great hall
however john's main focus was who
entered the great hall last
cersei's brothers the lannisters of
casterly rock
the lion and the dwarf there was no
mistaking which was which
jaime lannister was tall and golden with
flashing green eyes and a smile that cut
like valerian steel
they called him the lion a lannister to
his face and whispered king slayer
behind his back
what's interesting is jon was not able
to stop looking at him
jon can't help but think now this is
what a king should look like
i think this could be some misdirection
from george rr martin
and that's because right after jon
thinks jaime is what a king should look
like
he then has tyrion lannister walk in
next now
although he and jaime are brothers they
look nothing alike
as we go through these chapters i will
show you a lot of evidence that may or
may not suggest tyrion lannister has
king's blood
the blood of a dragon just like jon snow
tyrion lannister and jon snow might be
related
and what makes john's first chapter so
interesting is how it has some evidence
that also indicates
tyrion very well could be a targaryen
like him
maybe just maybe this is why jon and
tyrion form an
almost immediate connection with one
another now for those of you that might
not know
or just need a refresher let me tell you
one of the main reasons why many fans
believe in this theory
let me show you what barristan selmy
said to daenerys once she asked him to
tell her everything he knew about her
father
now we all know barristan selmy is a
very honorable man
so he has no reason to lie and i must
say what he says is fascinating
selmy says danny's father king aerys
when he was a youth he was taken with a
certain lady of casterly rock
a cousin of tywin lannister when that
cousin and tywin wed
your father drank too much wine at the
wedding feast and he was heard to say
that it was a great pity that the lord's
right to the first night
had been abolished a drunken jape no
more
but tywin lannister was not a man to
forget such words
or the the liberties your father took
during the betting
his face reddened i have said too much
your grace
now if you read between the lines
barristan selmy more or less says
aries targaryen might have had sex with
tyrion's mother on the night of her
wedding
many months before tyrion was actually
born so if you believe
jon snow is a targaryen don't you find
it interesting that a lot of the
evidence for tyrion being a targaryen
also shows up in jon snow's chapters i
know i do
let me show you what jon notices as
jaime and tyrion walk into winterfell's
great hall during the feast
jon notices tyrion has one green eye and
one black eye
having different colored eyes is
something the targaryens are known for
as well as having violent eyes of course
then jon also notices tyrion has hair so
blonde that it's almost white
this is another thing that the
targaryens are known for
you see why some fans may start to
connect these dots
now i need you to remember this for
later because there is more evidence at
the end of the chapter
let's keep reading alright so the last
of the high lords to enter the great
hall were john's uncle
benjen stark of the night's watch and
eddard's ward
theon greyjoy benjen gave john a warm
smile as he went by
theon ignored him utterly but there was
nothing new in that
now i know theon is highborn and jon
technically is a bastard at this moment
but i wish jon would have slapped theon
in his mouth just to let him know he
better show some respect
when jon feels something rub against his
leg he looks under the table
and sees red eyes staring back at him
you guessed it
ghost is hungry he's such a good boy
so john thinks about giving ghost a like
from one of the chickens
then he just decides to give him the
whole bird john swallows another gulp of
wine as he watches ghosts devour the
chicken
now there were also several dogs in the
great hall as well
one of them gets a whiff of the chicken
ghost is eating and attempts to take it
away from ghost
but it doesn't end the way she had hoped
she growls
and snaps but ghost just sits there in
silence
with his glowing red eyes standing over
the chicken
this other dog was three times larger
than ghost
but she ultimately ends up backing down
from the challenge
jon can't help but grin and give his
good boy a nice ruffle on his shaggy
white fur
then jon hears a familiar voice ask is
this one of the dire wolves i've heard
so much about
jon looked up happily as his uncle
benjen ruffled his hair
the same way he had just done to ghost
benjen grabs the cup out of john's hand
he said summer wine after he had a taste
nothing so sweet
how many cups have you had john john
couldn't help but just smile
his uncle benjen laughed and said as i
feared
ah well i believe i was younger than you
the first time i got truly and sincerely
drunk
there was always a hint of laughter in
his blue gray eyes
now don't all of you just love uncle
benjen he's like a more
laid-back version of ned but speaking of
ned benjen notices his brother isn't
having very much fun
benjen says my brother doesn't seem very
festive tonight
jon had noticed this too a bastard had
to learn to notice things
to read the truth hiding behind the eyes
this is how jon was able to size
everyone up as they walked into the
great hall
so john may know some things after all
now when it comes to ned not seeming
very festive tonight i will
say in his defense he is the one who has
to hang out with the lannisters during
the feast
how could anyone have fun while sitting
anywhere near cersei
jon noticed that cersei seemed cold as
an ice sculpture
and john knows exactly why she's so
upset that's because
ned took robert down into the crypts to
see lyanna
cersei obviously did not want him to go
now although cersei has no love for
robert
she still gets jealous over a woman who
has been dead for well over a decade
benjen says you don't miss much do you
john
we could use a man like you on the wall
the sound of that made jon very happy
he felt wanted he felt needed john says
rob is a stronger lance than i am but
i'm the better sword
and holland says i set a horse as well
as anyone in the castle
this is interesting because lyanna was
also known to be very comfortable on a
horse
benjen follows this up by saying those
are notable achievements john
so john says then take me with you when
you go back to the wall
father will give me leave to go if you
ask him i know he will
the scene is nearly identical to the one
we saw in the show
the only difference is this one happens
inside winterfell
whereas in the show it happened out in a
courtyard
now what they say next that wasn't in
the show is very interesting
some of you may have already heard me
talk about this if you watched my video
where i showed all the book evidence
that indicates jon snow is a king
this is when jon mentioned someone by
the name of darren targaryen
he says darren was only 14 years old
when he conquered dorne
the same age as john in this chapter the
young dragon was one of john's heroes
but benjen reminds jon of how that story
ends
he says your boy king lost thousands of
men taking dorne
and another 50 000 trying to hold it
someone should have told him that war
isn't a game also darren was only 18
years old when he died
or have you forgotten that so as you can
see
jon has a lot of interesting
similarities to this darren targaryen
they both achieve a lot at a very young
age but they also both die at a very
young age although i believe jon will be
resurrected in the books
jon tells benjen about how much he has
thought about this decision
to serve in the night's watch he says
someday robb will inherit winterfell
and command great armies as the warden
of the north bran and rickon will go on
to become robb's bannermen
and rule holdfasts in his name arya and
sansa will go on to marry the heirs of
other great houses
but what can a bastard like jon hope to
earn
there is nothing here for jon he says a
bastard can have honor too
i am ready to swear your oath benjen
says
come back to me after you've fathered a
few bastards of your own
and we'll see how you feel this made jon
furious
he says i will never father a bastard
never
he sped it out like venom only then is
when john realizes how loud he was
speaking
everyone else at the table fell silent
now they're all staring back at him
jon was so upset he had to excuse
himself from the feast
he ran out of the room before anyone
could see him cry like many of us who
have drank a lot at one time or another
you don't realize how drunk you are
until you stand up
that's exactly what happens to jon now
if things weren't bad enough
it only got worse when jon went to run
out of the room he slams into a serving
girl
as he's leaving knocking everything she
was holding onto the floor
now everyone begins laughing at jon he
let his emotions get the best of him
but you know alcohol tends to do that so
john and ghost go running outside into
the courtyard and this is when jon meets
tyrion lannister
as jon is out here he hears someone say
boy
when jon looks to see where the noise
came from he notices tyrion was sitting
on the ledge above the door to the great
hall
as you can see this is not how jon and
tyrion meet in the show
in the book version tyrion is sitting on
the ledge of the building like he's a
gargoyle
tyrion is curious about ghost he wants
to have a closer look at him
john hesitates at first but he does
allow it he asks tyrion if he's able to
climb down himself
or does he need a ladder this is when
tyrion shows us he could be in circus
delay
he throws himself off the ledge into the
empty air
john is shocked but he watches it all as
tyrion lannister spun around in the ball
landed lightly on his hands then vaulted
backward onto his legs
he's like a little ninja even ghost
backs away from him with uncertainty
now most of this interaction unfolds the
same way it does in the show
what i want to focus on is how the scene
ends after tyrion jumps down off the
ledge
he spends a few moments with ghost but
then he introduces himself to jon
he says i am tyrion lannister but jon
already knows that
as we all know tyrion is the most famous
dwarf in all the seven kingdoms
but then tyrion says you're ned stark's
bastard
aren't you now we all know jon doesn't
like to be called that
but he's still very angry from what just
happened inside with his uncle
so he feels even more offended than he
usually does
tyrion notices this and says i'm sorry
but you are the bastard though
jon says lord eddard stark is my father
and tyrion says yes i can see it you
have more the north than you than your
brothers
this is something that does make jon
happy to hear he just wants to feel like
he's one of the starks
but he doesn't let this show on his face
then tyrion gives him one of the most
famous lines from the story
one of my favorite lines if i might add
now let me just show you because after
this is when things get very interesting
let me give you some advice bastard
never forget what you are the rest of
the world will not
wear it like armor and it can never be
used to hurt you
jon was not in the mood for anyone's
advice john says what do you know about
being a bastard
tyrion says all dwarves are bastards in
their father's eyes
so john says but aren't you your
mother's true
born son tyrion says am i
do tell my lord father my mother died
giving birth to me
and he's never been sure now i'm sure
most of you remember this from the show
but tywin never believed that tyrion was
his son
he most likely knew the mad king was his
real father
because of what happened during the
night he wed tyrion's mother
not only that but i think taiwan was
smart enough to see that tyrion had some
of the targaryen's features
like the different colored eyes and the
white blonde hair
but i want to show you how the chapter
ends because this is even more
fascinating than what i've shown you
thus far when tyrion goes to leave the
courtyard
he opens the door in the light from
within the room throws his shadow across
the yard
and for just a moment it says tyrion
lannister stood tall as a king
i believe george r martin is definitely
giving us something to think about
i can't help but wonder why are all
these lines about tyrion and jon snow's
chapters
another character who is a secret
targaryen i would like to know what all
of you think about the theory
i've never made a video about this
before so i really don't know what my
subscribers think about it
now keep in mind there is a whole lot
more evidence than just this
i'm only showing you what was in john's
chapter but i will definitely show you
more
as we go through the other chapters in
the books
i want you to leave me your thoughts
down below i would love to see what you
have to say
like i said at the beginning of the
video if you would like to have early
access to my videos
and support the channel consider joining
me and everyone else over on my patreon
that would really help out a lot either
way i want to thank everyone for
watching the video
i hope you all have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you